so a classic-car is there's no
definition of a classic-car so it can be
anything from a 1899 Benz which you know
it's only got three wheels and a funny
engine in the back but it can be all the
way through to a very modern car one of
the very new cars it's it really spans
all eras the this classic car seen every
era has different interests different
buyers the the eighties phenomenon as
people call it is is fascinating and its
really interesting so so you get a lot
of people that that are now you know
grown-up if you like and that had these
cars from the 80s on their posters in
there in the rooms you know like a
Ferrari Testarossa or a BMW m1 and and
the cars that they would dream of a
Lamborghini Countach you know as a child
I remember thinking the Countach was the
coolest car ever and so now you know you
couldn't afford it back then but now
people these guys have a job is theirs
they're successful and now they have the
means to be able to to buy that
childhood dream well you know the modern
generation of supercar is sort of the
the wedge shaped era of supercars
started with the Lamborghini Countach
show car which was unveiled I think 1971
and and the design of that original
Lamborghini Countach sort of became the
prototype or the archetype for all all
of the supercars that have followed
really up until the present day cars of
the 80s we've seen a great increase in
in price and there it's simple economics
it's supply and demand you know there is
only so many cars so many Lamborghini
Countach --is there's only so many and
as they've grown a popularity there's
more people that want to buy them their
25th anniversary Countach to give an
example I remember three four years ago
when you'd be lucky to get 125 150 grand
for one and you know all of a sudden
they're three hundred fifty four hundred
thousand dollar cars
you know all of a sudden they're 350
$400,000 cars you know so they have they
have gone up in value by a a multiple of
what they traded for you know just a few
short years ago so the 80s cars I think
is is is I can see is attracting to the
new collectors new people that come to
the car market it's a great starting
point for someone that wants to get into
into classic cars and and it's a bit
younger a younger clientele so so the
guys that you know in the 80s were let's
say teenagers those are sort of the ones
that are buying most of those those 80s
cars because they can they can they can
remember them